nous avons maintenant à rendez-vous avec
jacques chancel qui se trouve dans un
autre studio de la rtf dire aux buttes
chaumont pour une émission que vous
allez voir ce soir à partir de je crois
20h30 oui c'est 20h30 toute façon pierre
guillermo va pouvoir nous le confirmer
puisqu'il se trouve actuellement sur le
plateau des répétitions de jacques
chancel pour le grand échiquier de ce
soir pierre à toi en effet jean-michel
au studio 12 on procède aux dernières
répétitions du grand échiquier jacques
chancel vous passez un petit peu fatigué
c'est le trac le manque de sommeil
qu'est ce que nous voulons c'est une
vilaine grippe mais j'espère que ce soir
il n'y paraîtra riols lorsque loossois
américain oui ça se voit mais je suis
sûr que ce soir tout ira bien
lorsque vous rencontrez qu'on parle
télévision pense immédiatement aux à la
série des dix grands amphis il est
proposé aux téléspectateurs depuis le
mois d'avril dernier
en quoi l'émission le grand échiquier
sera d'abord je voudrais aussi d'une
vision tout à fait différente
il ya eu le grand amphi le grand amphi
nous l'avons fait 10 à me lévy nous
allons faire une trop belle était
mauvais les scieries délits sont très
bonnes là nous sommes partis pour une
série de treize nous ne dépasserons pas
le cap des 13 le grand échiquier et une
issue différente parce que nous prenons
tous les risques
cette fois ci tous les risques du direct
d'abord nous l'émission durera trois
heures nous serons en relais avec à peu
près toute la france ce soir
simplement toulouse bordeaux lyon j'en
passe ensuite barcelone dont j'ai
l'étrange et barcelone et ensuite il ya
eu une aventure satellite car nous irons
à new york et à los angeles
alors oui c'est une aventure que se
passera-t-il si le satellite n'est pas
au rendez-vous mais simplement nous
auront tout tenté pour la voix nous
avons tout tenté pour avoir en direct
new yorkais n'ont pas eu la chance de la
voir en tout cas à new york nous avons
dave brubeck et son quartet qui nous
attend et à los angeles johnny mathis
donc sur le plan de la préparation je
crois que c'est bien très bien fait ici
sur le plateau ils montent en charge
alors il y aura beaucoup de mardi oui ça
c'est d'ailleurs il y avait une chose
très très amusante et très intéressante
et je remercie le journal télévisé info
première car grâce info première à 19h56
nous pourrons faire partir georges
brassens le verrou sur le studio ici aux
buttes chaumont est immédiatement une
voiture entre une voiture entrera dans
le studio
piloté par jean pierre beltoise brassens
montera dans cette voiture finra du code
du bourget au bourget un avion à temps
brassens et c'est à lyon conduit
brassens du côté du béarn aux fins pays
basque béarn mais moi ça ne sait pas à
quel endroit exact il va et nous
terminerons la soirée avec brassens il
ya également de fausses moteur havok
grave au caire beaucoup de maires
marival oui c'est l'histoire d'une
religieuse qui étaient cloîtrés pendant
30 ans et qui étaient auparavant aux
pensionnaires de la comédie française
c'est l'histoire d'une vie donc
rendez-vous ce soir à 19 h 56 en quoi la
formation première pour le départ de
georges brassens puis à partir de 20h30
sur la première chaîne de télévision je
propose maintenant des coupes et la
bande de l'indicatif qui sera votre
rendez vous ce soir à 20h30 au revoir
je
rendez vous donc bien notés à partir de
ce soir 20h30 le grand échiquier avec
jacques chance